We know the boat travels upstream for 6 miles so here this is 6. The boat is
going to travel the same distance to return back from where it started, so we
know the downstream distance must also equal 6. We know the boat travels 12
miles per hour in still water. So that means with the current, we would add x
going downstream and that means going against the current. We would subtract x,
that would be moving upstream. The key idea is that for the boat's rate, we let
the speed of the current equal x. So the boat would be traveling faster going
downstream, and slower going upstream. And finally, for our time column, we
know that we just need to take the distance, and divide it by the rate. So,
going upstream, the boat would take 6 divided by 12 minus x hours. And going
downstream, the boat would take 6 divided by 12 plus x hours. Fantastic work if
you've done all these expressions, this is pretty tricky.